- Good afternoon, thank
you so much for coming
to the second annual Canvas
@ Yale lightning talks.
I'm very excited to have a
bunch of great presenters today
and I just want to thank
everyone who helped out
with the set up today, who
helped getting everybody ready
and this was a labor of love.
Thank you so much to everyone who helped
make this happen here today.
I want to jump right in and
get started on everything.
So the first thing here, we have Julia,
who's going to be our presenter.
Julia is a senior lector
in the Slavic department
and is a Canvas quiz guru.
Aside from teaching Julia
has published articles
in a lot of national peer review journals
and is also interested in
working with technology,
digital humanities and
heritage language learning.
Today she's going to be talking
about how she integrated
the Canvas quizzes into her course.
- Thank you so much.
Thank you for coming, it's great to see
so many familiar faces and
some of you teach language too
so I hope that you would find
this presentation helpful
because as I was telling
Timberley language teachers
invariably do a lot of grading.
I will tell you a little
bit about the structure
of this course and why I
find Canvas so so helpful.
So I teach and oversee
introductory Russian,
first year Russian.
As many introductory
language courses at Yale
it has multiple sections.
So I'm the course coordinator,
I oversee multiple sections.
I get every year new teaching assistants
who have never taught before
so obviously one of the paramount tasks
is to ensure that grading is consistent
across multiple sections.
As anybody who has been in
a similar situation knows
it is very difficult for
an experienced teacher
to teach a new teacher to
grade exactly like yourself
because it's not just
finding the correct answer
that you can teach them to
do, you will give the key,
that's not the problem.
But to make sure how certain
components of the test
are evaluated as a whole.
Is it worth one point,
is it worth half a point,
is it considered a spelling error,
is it considered repeated error
in which case you would not
and so forth.
Again, the other challenge that we have
in introductory language classes,
we want to give these quizzes
and exams fairly often.
We cannot teach a class where
we'll just give a midterm
and the final, that would
have disastrous results.
I know that majority of
my colleagues and as do we
in Russian, we have bi-weekly unit tests.
That means they're graded,
students get the letter
or in Canvas cases a percentage grade
and on the weeks that are
off weeks from the tests,
we have what we call low stakes quizzes.
That is to say this would also be a quiz
but it will be shorter and
instead of a letter grade
you will have a percentage.
Why do we do that?
We fill that in the introductory
level it's very important
to have this what we call level checks
or progress measurements.
Because if student gets a very low score
on this interim low stake quiz
then it tells them okay well
the material in this unit
really needs more work so
by the time they approach
the unit test they will have
already had that feedback.
Again, I know that this is something
that I see Sherry in Hebrew
and Angela in Korean,
we all have this approach.
It's very important to give
the student frequent feedback.
At the same time, in paper testing,
it also in addition to obvious
challenges for uniformity
of grading as I said,
there was another challenge
of simply if you correct mistake by hand
the student may or may
not be able to decipher
what you wrote.
It's a huge problem in
the larger assignments
because each test invariably
has a free writing portion
and I'll show you in a minute.
Whether they are able
to read your corrections
God only knows.
Whether they read it
you don't know either.
So in Canvas it's taken
care of beautifully
because you can type your feedback
and student will immediately see it.
You will also set up the
test and I will show you,
where the correct answers
are immediately shown.
We've used this feature
typically we use this
feature because at Yale
fortunately we don't have a problem
with academic dishonesty
so once you hit submit
you will immediately see
just like you do now on SAT.
You will have your own score.
By own score I mean of
course then I will invariably
go into the exam and
make sure that machine
has subtracted the points correctly.
There is also free writing
portion of each test
which the Canvas can
now currently not grade
but I will grade by hand
and I will leave comments.
For us, using Canvas in first year Russian
has proven to be of tremendous benefit
both on the learners progress,
because then it assures transparency,
students see exactly what went wrong.
On consistency of grading,
then there are no more debates
or you've taken for this,
you didn't take for that
and so forth, it cross sections.
Of course, the frequent feedback.
Finally, there is a great
organizational benefit
because we've all been in the situation
when student is sick or
they have to go out of town
in other words they
have a legitimate excuse
that they cannot take
their test with a group
and then you have to
somehow make arrangements
so that they have to come
in during the office hours
and even on organization
level it's very difficult
because you have to
find mutually convenient
time to proctor.
Again, Canvas takes care of it wonderfully
because you as the teacher if you know
the reason is legitimate you
can open the test on demand.
Which sometimes we do
and it works beautifully.
What else we do?
Presume your student
did very poorly on exam
and it's up to the teacher to decide
how you want to approach it.
Presume somebody got very stressed
or they had some sort of issue
and they got very low score
then you can go into the test
and allow second attempt.
It will be measured.
So now I will demonstrate for you,
I mean I put on the
abstract that I will
show you my full semester
but that doesn't really matter
because I am working with this now.
So this is my second semester of this.
Again I've used it last year too
so it's the second year or
the fourth semester of this.
So how it works, so quizzes.
So the children are not confused.
So each chapter is
organized into these modules
so you can see in January
we started with unit seven.
There is a vocabulary quiz
because I've said when they will do.
And then there is a chapter test
which is invariably last.
So what do I do with a unit
test, low stake quizzes?
All quizzes are worth only
ten percent of total grade
so again it's that low stake testing
which research has shown
has tremendous benefits
because you want to test without students
being too stressed about it.
So I will preview so you see
what the test looks like.
I don't know if I can go
and show in the privacy
interest the quiz statistics.
So it looks like this.
You can set it up, it's just
a simple vocabulary quiz.
Everybody does it, it's very standard.
So from English into Russian
then you have some components,
well on this one it's only
from English into Russian
but usually I set up two ways.
If it's a vocabulary quiz it will be
from into the target language
then from the target
language back into English.
You can of course change it at any time.
What is super nice about this
if you want to see how people
did in the particular section
or across the board if
your quiz was set up well
you go into this
and it will show you overall performance
so you see people did pretty good.
I don't know if it shows
me the average score, 90%.
Very nice.
Obviously it was set up well.
I'll show you one more thing
because I get the card for questions.
I'll show you the test,
you want to see the test.
A little bit, just one,
because they do say they want to see.
So grading is beautiful.
Listening of course,
nobody has any problems
with listening.
So green you don't worry about the green.
So red, of course, you have
to see how Canvas scores it.
So here there was nothing for me to do
because I went in and there was issues,
there were various issues here,
it's not the best test to show of course.
But in any case, so the
green one you don't even
have to worry, it's tremendous time saver
because green you just scroll.
Red one you should see.
Like here you see I
awarded two and half points
because I gave you back
half the credit for here
because there is a spelling error.
So on the red one you
look and then you go,
again this is a very poor example to show
because this is very bad work,
but this is the free writing.
So this is the free writing
for the free writing prompt,
so students write then I can,
when I get here I say
look this is always worth
14 out of possible 20 points,
then I tell her here why it is
because I have this comment, you see,
where I correct her issues.
Here for overall comment
I didn't say anything
but it allows you to put the comments in.
This work was turned
in late, you see that,
so it's very nice.
If you have multiple
attempts it will show you.
Well this is obviously
a very good work 99.5.
It's wonderful because then they can see
immediately the problems,
what they need to work
on and improve.
Again I can go back to quiz statistics
and I will see how the sections did.
Questions?
- [Woman] Are these in
class tests and quizzes
or are these taken online?
- So unit tests, the one
that you're looking at now,
will be taken in class
because there is also
a listening component that I will play,
that they don't have listened to before,
this will be played in class.
So anything that they get a letter grade
and these are weighted heavier
because unit tests count
for 40% of the grade.
So yes I will do that in class.
Vocabulary quizzes which was
the first item demonstrated,
vocabulary quizzes are
considered low stake item
and those will be done out
of class, out of class time.
But that's a good point because
what I intend to do later,
like maybe next academic year,
I want to add more of
these low stake quizzes.
So rather than giving
one a week maybe I'll
give a couple a week.
Because how else can you
make them learn vocabulary.
You've seen that problem.
- [Man] Who set up your Canvas presence?
Did you do it yourself or
did you hire an expert?
- Well I had great help
from Christine Constantina
and so we worked together.
She was very generous with her time
and thanking both Timberly and Christine
have really helped tremendously.
Now every time I have a
problem because I still do
I ask Christine and she helps me.
The more you use it the better it gets.
The first time I thought it was horrible
because every answer is a new screen.
But eventually you get the hang of it.
Again, truth be told it is
time consuming to set up
but it's absolutely well worth it
because last year we spent
tremendous amount of time
setting it up but now it's all there
so now I can concentrate
on more define and adding
because also I'm sure
somebody will talk about it,
Canvas has this beautiful
button copy resources
of which I can happily
talk about next time
because resources are
much easier to maintain
and copy from semester to semester.
I'm a huge fan of this
program, absolutely.
- [Woman] So for the
order of the questions
can you shuffle words or order?
- You can, for my particular
situation it's not practical
but yes absolutely.
When you set up the quiz
you can absolutely do.
You can have bank of
questions and it will pick
from the bank.
For us, because the first
year on introductory languages
are so sequential,
I can do it in my other class for example,
I can advance to whatever heritage.
But in the introductory language level
the points that you wish to test
are so few and so particular
that you don't want to.
So the answer is yes,
the system allows it,
but we don't do it for
this particular course.
- [Timberley] Great thank you so much.